I'm sitting in a bar with a couple of
friends literally a couple married
couple they're the parents of two young
children seven academic degrees between
them big nerds really nice people but
very sleep-deprived and they asked me
the question I get asked more than any
other question they go so Emily how uh
how do couples you know sustain a strong
sexual connection over multiple decades
I'm a sex educator which is why my
friends ask me questions like this and I
am also a big nerd like my friends I
love science which is why I can give
them something like an answer research
actually has pretty solid evidence that
couples who sustained strong sexual
connections over multiple decades have
two things in common before I can tell
my friends what those two things are I
have to tell them a few things that they
are not these are not couples who have
sex very often almost none of us have
sex very often we are busy they are also
not couples who necessarily have wild
adventurous sex one recent study
actually found that the couples who are
most strongly predicted to have strong
sexual and relationship satisfaction the
best predictor of that is not what kind
of sex they have or how often or where
they have it but whether they cuddle
after sex and they are not necessarily
couples who constantly can't wait to
keep their hands off each other
some of them are they experienced what
the researchers call spontaneous desire
that just sort of seems to appear out of
the blue Erica Moen the cartoonist who
illustrated my book draws spontaneous
desire as a lightning bolt to the
genitals kaboom you just want it out of
the blue that is absolutely one normal
healthy way to experience sexual desire
but there's another healthy way to
experience sexual desire it's called
responsive desire where spontaneous
desire seems to emerge in
of pleasure responsive desire emerges in
response to pleasure there's a sex
therapist New Jersey named Christine
Hyde who taught me this great metaphor
she uses with her clients she says
imagine that your best friend invites
you to a party
you say yes because it's your best
friend and a party but then as the date
approaches you start thinking oh there's
gonna be all this traffic we have to
find childcare am I really gonna want to
put my party clothes on and get there at
the end of the week but you put on your
party clothes and you show up to the
party and what happens you have a good
time at the party if you are having fun
at the party you are doing it right when
it comes to a sexual connection it's the
same thing you put on your party clothes
you set up a childcare you put your body
in the bed you let your skin touch your
partner's skin and allow your body to
wake up and remember all right I like
this I like this person that's
responsive desire and it is key to
understanding the couples who sustain a
strong sexual connection over the long
term because and this is the part where
I tell my friends the two
characteristics of the couples who do
sustain a strong sexual connection one
they have a strong friendship at the
foundation of their relationship
specifically they have strong trust
relationship researcher and therapist
developer of emotionally focused therapy
sue Johnson Boyles trust down to this
question are you there for me especially
are you emotionally present and
available for me friends are there for
each other one the second characteristic
is that they prioritize sex they decide
that it matters for their relationship
they choose to set aside all the other
things that they could be doing but
children they could be raising and the
jobs they could be going to the other
family members to pay attention to the
other friends they might want to hang
out with god forbid they just want to
watch some television or go to sleep
stop doing all that stuff and create a
protected space where all you're gonna
do is put your body in the bed and let
your skin touch your
your skin so that's it best friends
prioritize sex so I said this to my
friends in the bar I was like best
friends prioritize sex I told him about
the party I said you put your skin next
to your partner's skin and one of the
partners
I was talking to goes and I was like
okay so there's your problem the
difficulty was not that they did not
want to go to the party necessarily if
the difficulty is just a lack of
spontaneous desire for parties you know
what to do you put on your party clothes
and you show up for the party if you're
having fun at the party you're doing it
right there difficulty was that this was
a party where she didn't love what there
was available to eat the music was not
her favorite music and she wasn't
totally sure she feel great about her
relationship with the people who were at
the party and this happens all the time
nice people who love each other come to
dread sex these couples if they seek sex
therapy the therapist might have them
stand up and put as much distance
between their bodies as they need in
order to feel comfortable and the less
interested partner will make 20 feet of
space and the really difficult part is
that space is not empty it is crowded
with weeks or months or more of the
you're not listening to me and I don't
know what's wrong with me but your
criticism isn't helping and if you loved
me you would and you're not there for me
years maybe of all these difficult
feelings in the book I use this really
silly metaphor of difficult feelings as
sleepy hedgehogs that you are fostering
until you can find a way to set them
free by turning toward them with
kindness and compassion and the couples
who struggle to maintain a strong sexual
connection the distance between them is
corroded with these sleepy hedgehogs and
it happens in any relationship that
lasts long enough you two are fostering
a prickle of sleepy hedgehogs between
you and your certain special someone the
difference between couples who sustain a
strong sexual connection and the ones
who don't is not that they don't
experience these difficult hurt feelings
it's that they
turn toward those difficult feelings
with kindness and compassion so that
they can set them free and find their
way back to each other
so my friends in the bar are faced with
the question under the question not how
do we sustain a strong connection but
how do we find our way back to it and
yes there is science to answer this
question but in 25 years as a sex
educator one thing I have learned is
sometimes Emily less science more
hedgehogs so I told him about me I spent
many months writing a book about the
science of women's sexual well-being I
was thinking about sex all day every day
and I was so stressed by the project
that I had zero zero interest in
actually having any sex and then I spent
months traveling all over talking with
anyone who would listen about the
science of women's sexual well-being and
by the time I got home you know I'd show
up for the party put my body in the bed
let my skin touch my partner's skin and
I was so exhausted and overwhelmed I
would just cry and fall asleep and the
months of isolation fostered fear and
loneliness and frustration so many
hedgehogs my best friend this person I
love and admire felt a million miles
away but he was still there for me
no matter how many difficult feelings
there were he turned toward them with
kindness and compassion he never turned
away and what was the second
characteristic of couples who sustained
a strong sexual connection they
prioritize sex they decide that it
matters for their relationship that they
do what it takes to find their way back
to the connection I told my friends what
sex therapists and researcher Peggy
Klein plot says she asks what kind of
sex is worth wanting My partner and I
looked at the quality of our connection
and what it brought to our lives and we
looked at the family of sleepy hedgehogs
I had introduced into our home and we
sited it was worth it we decided we
chose to do what it took to find our way
turning toward each of those sleepy
hedgehogs those difficult hurt feelings
with kindness and compassion and setting
them free so that we could find our way
back to the connection that mattered for
our relationship this is not the story
we are usually told about how sexual
desire works in long-term relationships
but I can think of nothing more romantic
nothing sexier than being chosen as a
priority because that connection matters
enough even after I introduced all of
these difficult feelings into our
relationship how do you sustain a strong
sexual connection over the long term you
look into the eyes of your best friend
you keep choosing to find your way back
thank you
[Applause]